Ankur Gupta: Hello, everyone. Thank you so much, Taru. So, we are Prashantan Deepika, our community coaches are Bumesh and Bumika. So, yeah, today my topic is how I'm building relationship with clients for a long time.
Ankur Gupta: So, first of all, client co, long-term relationship, it's… that work starts from day one. When we are starting their program, that time itself, I'm…
Ankur Gupta: Giving their, apart from follow-up also, I'm doing like caring calls weekly, to, to, if they are facing any difficulty or chani lagra or sometimes it's not related to their health also, sometimes emotional also, right, say they are emotionally down or something happens in the family if they are calling me for any time, I'm there for them.
Ankur Gupta: If I just thought taro said just now, I can listen to them, so they can see. That's how the relationship started.
Ankur Gupta: And thing is that, I think 5, beyond 5 years, 5 to 3 years, I think 8 to 10 clients connected hai, if they are doing nothing also, may jasi ki anniversary hoge birthday hoge dashira di Valli New Year, may koshish kartum, apart from message ki may call kartung message kartha hai to the pointe 2, 3.
Ankur Gupta: their parents are not good, feeling not good. So, there's the things going on. So, most of the clients based.
Ankur Gupta: I personally visited them. If they are far of 40, 50 kilometer distance also me jaati huake agar baca hai, to unkile bot me gift le ke jaati ho as a family. Tus next level of relation build hot.
Ankur Gupta: program start ho gay extend hoge kisi ka. Or in sub process may references just buy a product.
Ankur Gupta: pregnancy ko le ke bossare.
Ankur Gupta: complications face me gratitude and self-talk about. So unseung, like.
Ankur Gupta: 3 years old cliente, Usnam areas are connected, or through social media. They are all C-list.
Ankur Gupta: So, social media connected hui because of her pre-wedding weight loss, she done it. After wedding 6 months, she called me. After 6 months pregnancy plan karna, apatause ka precaution le na hai. Then I again enrolled for her WQ program.
Ankur Gupta: Then after that, within 6 months, she conceived. After that one year, throughout the pregnancy also, whatever the issues happen, and then diabetes deducted, all those things. And she told her gynecologist also, I have that kind of nutritionist course she is guiding me.
Ankur Gupta: And gynecologist also said, you provide the diet and all those, it is all over the correct.
Ankur Gupta: And then after the last month, she delivered a baby boy. She used to write in her gratitude also, I want a baby boy. So, finally, she got a baby boy last month, and then she again, she called me, okay, now I… what I need to do?
Ankur Gupta: Then again, I follow, so it's just continuing in between her mother also came, her father also came, her husband, even mother-in-law also came, that's the thing, Luke is going on.
Ankur Gupta: going on, when we meet specially, that is the magic, when we physical meeting. That's the thing. And one more client is there. She, I think 5 years before, she connected me for her hair fall solution. After 2 years, she said, okay, I want to plan for a second pregnancy.
Ankur Gupta: for… she has tumor and other complications, and that testimony published also in WQ community. And then after that, also, her mother, her friends, her sister, her brother, everywhere, you know, all over India, they are in here and there, but all of them are migrants.
Ankur Gupta: So that's the thing. It started from day one, actually, not in the midwin, and then it's still continuing. My goal is to build the friendship so it can continue and continue.
Ankur Gupta: That's the thing. That's it, Taloo.
Ankur Gupta: Excuse me?
Ankur Gupta: If you can take back, um, actionables, right? So what is working for Deepika?
Ankur Gupta: So, first of all, first of all, before the actionables, there's a lot of hope, right? Somebody who worked with you.
Ankur Gupta: Before the wedding, then weight loss after the wedding, or before planning a pregnancy, then third, how do I take care of my health after I deliver baby? Fourth, what do I do to lose postpartum weight?
Ankur Gupta: That means the same person actually is going to be, she is going to come to Deepika for her 4th CMOS.
Ankur Gupta: That's a lot of home. And besides that, there is referrals, right? Mother, mother-in-law, spouse, this, that, all that, that is.
Ankur Gupta: Definitely there, so it's the same, first of all, I hope this expands your mind about the possibilities.
Ankur Gupta: The same person has done her 3rd CMOS with Deepika over a span of 3 years or 5 years, whatever the example was.
Ankur Gupta: Similarly, in the other case also, right, 1 CMOS, 2 years later, second CMOS, then another CMOS.
Ankur Gupta: Now, definitely in between, what is, what are the actionables that are clearly working for Deepika.
Ankur Gupta: Number 1, she's not limiting herself only to the follow-up call. The weekly follow-up is a sacrosanct thing.
Ankur Gupta: No compromise there, but besides that, there's a chit-chat call that works for her. See, it's personality dependent also, so for some of you, it may not work, ignore it, but for some of you, this can work.
Ankur Gupta: That, okay, I'll just do a 5 minutes, 10 minutes connect call, and it is not like a review call, it is just a chit-chat call, like, you know, you get to know the client better, types, right?
Ankur Gupta: But it's personality dependent, yours as well as the client's. So this is one thing that is working for Deepika, one additional call.
Ankur Gupta: during the week, which is not the review call. Review call is separate. That's the professional systematic flow of your follow-up and things like that. That is one.
Ankur Gupta: The second thing which is constantly, which has worked for her over the years is physically meeting people. You all know about gifts, right? Whenever you make the effort.
Ankur Gupta: People can see your heart, people can see your intention, and people.
Ankur Gupta: see you as a real person and not somebody they've interacted only Zoom and Zoom and Zoom and Zoom.
Ankur Gupta: Right, it takes it to the next level, correct? And third, naturally.
Ankur Gupta: You're not limiting yourself from giving them value adds even when they're not on your program, right? She's saying small, small things.
Ankur Gupta: she was disturbed or stressed during pregnancy. Obviously, Deepika didn't charge her for that. She was not her coach, right? During pregnancy, whatever disturbances she had in her life, Deepika was just connecting as a friend.
Ankur Gupta: Nonetheless, later she came back to her. So if I tell you the actionables, these are 3 things.
Ankur Gupta: Don't think small about giving value adds when they are not on your program.
Ankur Gupta: Now, these are things from your side. The smart thing that you would have to do is.
Ankur Gupta: keep them in your micro-communities, make sure that you're in touch over WhatsApp status and chats also.
Ankur Gupta: They have, you have to be visible because if they're not watching Deepika, they'll slip, right?
Ankur Gupta: Correct? So these are, so in spirit and in actions, this is what you can, at least these are the minimums you can apply from her talk.
Ankur Gupta: Awesome.